nicole cornu langlois et hay est à nous
raconter une belle histoire d'amour
l'histoire d'une jeune femme et d'un
jeune homme qui réhabilite le mariage et
qui finissent par s'unir après où malgré
un parcours affectif et sexuel très
riche c'est du cinéma institutions
universel le mariage fait toujours
recette
c'est le prétexte à réunir des amis et
provoquer ainsi des rencontres qui
entraîneront d'autres mariages mais il
faudra bien quatre mariages et un
enterrement pour que l'indépendante
carrie andie macdowell et charles
célibataire désinvolte et très british
une grande devienne un vrai couple
justement là
troisièmement il ne veut pas de mal à
cela
je trouve que c'est parce que pour un
homme c'est normal mais dès qu'une femme
120 c'est choquant alors que je le
trouve très bien car
pourquoi pas
quelle crise
tu vas où
québec
c'est du passé
toutefois elle est différente je ne
ressemble pas à la petite anglaise
modèle elle est américaine elle est
presque trop jolie pour être honnête ils
ont presque coupé de shell a un grand
sens de l'humour elle parle très
naturellement de sa sexualité
et lui n'est pas du tout habitué à cela
un thème américaine
et vous en dis comment était votre
mariage nous nous sommes mariés au
sommet d'une montagne c'était
paradisiaques et un ami à moi a
interprété à la guitare une chanson
j'aimerais une énorme cérémonie avait
des têtes couronnées à l'abbaye de
westminster monaco ou quelque chose
comme cela
monaco certains clichés sont aussi
tenace d'enlèvement que les happy end en
forme de bizet comme dans ce film
si vous aimez rire vous devez écouter
france inter chaque jour à midi ce riz